good morning hey abby what are we doing
today
welcome to 73 questions with vogue
i'm just kidding maybe one day but i'm
gonna take you inside my life for a
minute to show you all the ways that i'm
not that
girl
come with me
[Music]
so what the f is that girl well
according to my very scientific research
that girl is the wellness version of hot
girl summer they are the aesthetically
pleasing ladies all over your tick tock
feed that seemingly have their act all
together it's about self-fulfillment
achieving goals productivity it's about
drive it's about power we stay hungry
and living your best life while
supporting wellness it's basically a
walking talking pinterest mood board and
let's be real i do not have the vibe
today i'm going to walk you through all
the ways that i'm not that girl but
first let me tell you about my sponsor
picnic so i come from a long line of
seasonal allergy sufferers and while i
know i am not alone more than 50 million
people in the states actually have
allergies the good news is i have a plan
for treating them so picnic makes
getting personalized effective allergy
treatment a total breeze with fda
approved medications personalized plans
high quality patient care and convenient
home delivery so you basically fill out
an online quiz created by expert
allergists to help you determine the
best treatment plan for you and you get
unlimited virtual access to a doctor for
follow-ups and treatment picnic offers
both over-the-counter and prescription
medications all of which are fda
approved and you never have to wait for
a doctor's appointment again and then
once you and your doctor have determined
the best treatment plan for you all of
your medications are shipped right to
your door we are really in the thick of
allergy season here where i live so i am
so excited to now have this personalized
plan so if you're one of the 50 million
allergy sufferers who still don't yet
have a proper treatment plan in place
you can use my link in the description
to get 50 off of your first order this
offer is valid for the first 100 people
who click so just take the quiz and the
promotion plus free shipping will be
added automatically so here's to a
sneeze free spring with picnic also a
quick disclaimer here including a huge
acknowledgement that i am very
privileged to have a beautiful home and
a beautiful family and a beautiful
fulfilling career this is not going to
be a commentary on material access so
much as a dietary lifestyle that society
continues to dictate that we need to
strive for the point of this video is to
demonstrate that all of the remarkable
blessings in the world don't necessarily
afford us the luxury of maintaining the
stereotypical perfect instagram life and
i don't know about you but the perfect
life for me is messy and imperfect let
me show you what i mean
and that's enough acting for today i
don't have time for lemon water in the
morning so i drink regular water and
then coffee because it is the only thing
that gives me life after my kids have
been screening my name for three hours
straight nobody parties harder than a
toddler at five a.m
[Music]
i do not have time to make a smoothie
bowl in the morning
and i really only get to have avocado
toast on like a weekend when the avocado
is perfect and my husband doesn't swipe
it before i can get to it so i usually
eat like the snotty leftovers from my
kids breakfast there's probably mucus in
this
the mucus queen
is yours
i don't meditate
or do yoga
or journal i'm sure these things would
be great for me but
if i wrote in my journal
this is what it would say i have so much
to do so yeah
the first thing i do in the morning is
not set my intentions for the day in a
romantic paperback i
look through the [ __ ] storm that is my
email mailbox and when i can't stand the
sound of my kids screaming anymore i get
out of bed and i put on my house coat
and i go get the kids oh and please tell
me i'm not the only one that leaves like
a bunch of half empty cans
all over the house let's do a counter
shall we
hey san pellegrino if you want to hit me
up for a sponsorship
i can be that girl
[Music]
oh hello
welcome to my bathroom this is where i
hide most mornings from my children
so i have a very simple
look
um i don't
really wear makeup five out of seven
days of the week
um and for my hair i usually have to
choose between like working out
getting some kind of work done or
washing my hair so
dry shampoo for the wind as for my
skincare i've definitely come a long way
i used to literally just kind of like
wash my face and take my makeup off
but your girl is getting older so um i
basically stick to whatever my
dermatologist recommended so it's some
kind of prescription um
creams and things like that because i
have keratosis polaris on my arms and i
have a little bit of redness on my face
so i stick to basics i wash my face i
take my makeup off i try to use like an
antioxidant serum and i try to use a
moisturizer but let's be real some days
aka most days when i'm exhausted at the
end of the day i just do the bare
minimum so yeah we keep it simple over
here
[Music]
all right makeup wise
i have got this down to a five minute
exercise because
your girl does not have an hour to
contour
nor do i know how so
my knowledge is limited but i get the
job done so
this is what i do
[Music]
time check
done
we're near the end
so i got this airwrap thing for
christmas
don't know how to use it
now which side is this
that way
yes
yes yes yes
so
oh god
it is a disaster zone
can you do like you have to do the
[Music]
20 hours later 24 hours later all right
not bad
that'll do
that'll do donkey
that'll do
so when we moved into this house we
didn't have kids so we bought all this
beautiful furniture that we thought fit
our aesthetic and we talked about vistas
and we talked about london townhouse
inspiration and now it just looks like a
rainbow threw up over everything and
honestly i have no
time or energy or
desire to fix or replace anything
because again i have two kids under four
and a dog so while most influencers
would take you on like a house tour
i'm partially too modest to do that but
also just way too lazy to clean up all
the that's on the floor so instead
i'm to take you on a deficiency tour as
a cautionary tale to anyone at home
who's decorating a house and also
thinking about having kids you've been
warned curtains
with
lots of food pieces on them likely from
flying spoons of yogurt oatmeal
and other
edibles way too expensive to dry clean
come come down here take a look at this
yeah you know those little sticky things
that kids like to put on windows
well mine put them on my designer
wallpaper and when they came off
left me a little something something to
remember the
incident
[Music]
yeah
love kids and this
amazing architectural choice
[Music]
texture texture
planes
trains and other automobiles
yes poppy
we see you
[Music]
oh hi yes
there was a toilet paper dispenser here
but
obviously my kids
pulled that off yeah
so the that girl look is obviously all
athleisure we've got the high waisted
leggings we've got the sports bra
and i rock that i mean with this gap
t-shirt that i got for free on top
obviously but
my signature look is the house coat
[Music]
i got three looks
and that's it
[Music]
here's the secret
i don't always make dinner from scratch
sometimes
i order in because
i'm a mom of two who's working and
trying to just
live another day in a pandemic and
that's okay
but it's not
that
girl well folks that is all that i have
for you guys today a big thank you to
picnic for sponsoring this video if you
like this video be sure to give it the
thumbs up
leave me a comment below on other fun
vlog videos you want to see me do
subscribe to the channel and i'll see
you next time on abby's kitchen bye
[Music]